all right what's going on guys this is
rob and this is my birthday week uh so
happy birthday to myself um with the
exception of the thor video which i
technically already recorded um i'm just
gonna be playing at low key this week
we've got a thor video we got beyond
omega level i'm just gonna relax this
week work on some stuff around the house
probably watch my car make some videos
on geek culture explain can be pretty
straightforward and pretty chill so
we're gonna be doing dark ages this week
and this story is amazing god i
absolutely love this story uh because
it's a new cosmic entity in marvel
comics plus it's got it's it's it's cool
i think you guys are really gonna take
it so what this does here is this
initially picks up in new jersey why
everybody's hanging out in new jersey
i'll never fully understand uh but
everybody's hanging out in new jersey
right and for the most part it's like
jessica jones and luke cage and mj and
and spider-man here's kind of a cool
thing right this story is written by tom
taylor i love the detail here and here's
the reason why so one of the things a
lot of people may not know when it comes
to the history of spider-man
particularly spider-man and jessica
jones is that when jessica jones
initially struck out to become a hero of
course she ran into the purple man and
the purple man screwed with her life and
did all kinds of terrible things and and
all that stuff but one of the things you
learned later on is that the reason why
jessica jones became a superhero is
because she idolized spider-man and so
it was cool to see her like literally
and some degree model herself after
peter parker albeit she's called herself
jewel and that kind of a thing but it is
still pretty cool to see here um and so
that's why the relationship really the
friendship between jessica jones and
peter parker has been so strong over the
years is because there was a depth to
their friendship that not even peter
parker was aware of and once he became
aware of that he was like i mean yeah
okay cool yeah we can be really cool
friends and we've been friends for a
while but i guess we're better friends
now you know that kind of a thing uh of
course you also have like peter parker's
daughter
him and mary jane watson are together in
this alternate reality uh and they have
a little girl and she's kind of doing
her thing and learning her powers and
all that kind of stuff and then suddenly
everybody's spider sense goes off now
the way it's explained here by peter
parker because this whole story is
largely given to us by way of a
monologue but you also get dialogue
between the individual characters peter
parker says it like the the spiders were
the ones who felt it first now it makes
the most sense here and this is one of
the other reasons why i love this is
because you would expect all the spiders
to feel at first just because of the
fact that the spider sense warns them of
impending danger and is kind of an early
alert system which is really one of the
only reasons why anyone in the
spider-man community is able to fight on
the level that they do against the kind
of foes that they face off against
otherwise they would just be killed
pretty quickly and there wouldn't really
be much going on there
but the thing about this is that it's
not really the fact that their spider
sense goes off it's the extreme degree
to which they feel it and that's what
really freaks out peter parker is
because he's like the only time that
i've ever really felt my spider since go
off this strong was when like galactus
was approaching earth but this was way
worse than that right this is this is
one of those things where it felt like
galactus was consuming the earth right
destruction the death of everything is
impending and so at this point we switch
over to lunella lafayette now i'm still
a little murky about moon girl and
here's the reason why i have been
reading comics forever
for so long and as long as i've been
alive since her introduction to the
point where she became really
significant in any measurable way
valeria richards has always been the
smartest kid in in the marvel universe
more recently it's moon girl the reality
here though is that
i kind of like the shift so i'm on the
fence
[Laughter]
on one hand i like the change of moon
girl being the being like the new girl
who's like the smartest girl in the
universe but at the same time i'm so
used to it being valeria richards
so i don't really know which way to go
here but regardless right moon girl
devil dinosaur which i always loved the
idea of moon girl and devil dinosaur her
idea is okay she starts picking up on
these patterns that nobody picks up on
right it's one of the things that makes
her one of the smartest people in the
world and in fact it's kind of
interesting because the way it's phrased
here the world's smartest person on her
way to the baxter building to talk to
the world's second smartest person which
that i will not accept i will never
accept
that reid richards or victor von doom
are not trading places as the smartest
person in the world i'm sorry i can't i
cannot you know you know what i probably
could accept that given enough time but
regardless it's not important the other
part of this is on the telepathic side
they start to pick up something saying
like the mind like a mind has woken up
in the earth and it's nothing like
they've ever felt before but while the
spiders are sensing this and and you
know moon girl is picking up on this and
the telepaths are picking up on this
somebody else is picking up on this as
well and that's apocalypse and that was
when this story won me over
i was a little unsure about it at first
i was like i mean i don't know if it's
gonna be good or not and then it's just
like apocalypse just being menacing and
doing apocalypse stuff and i was like so
so like at that point
it was just a matter of seeing how the
story unfolded spoiler alert i read
through this whole story in like an hour
and a half i blew through this whole
thing uh that's how much i loved it
that's how good it was so it was it was
it was phenomenal but essentially
everybody comes together at the baxter
building right they come together to
basically meet with reed richards and
the thing about this is that while
they're discussing and while they're
talking these tremors are being felt and
that's where you have and this is
something i would love to read actually
a team up book between um moon girl and
and valeria richards but the two of them
approach reed and moon girl kind of
presents her findings and she's like
here's the thing she was like the the
trimmers are not consistent with
tectonic plate shifts right the quakes
are simply just too short if this was
something where like the earth was
shifting right for by some man or by
some situation the tectonic plates of
the earth were moving around this is not
something that happens quickly right
they don't move super fast they don't
jolt in that way right plate tectonic
shifts create a lasting earthquake
feeling right i mean what they're
experiencing is literally somebody
pounding on a door and that's what moon
girl says is like we're being attacked
from inside the earth and that's when
valeria's like i think the world is
ending now at that point you get the
obligatory watcher appears yes
that kind of thing you know which is not
necessarily as impactful as it used to
be those of you guys who are new to
marvel comics there was a time when this
mattered dude there was a time when the
watcher showed up you were like damn son
all right dude it's about to pop off
when the watcher shows up now it's like
oh cool i want to all right cool so i
guess maybe something's going to happen
i don't really know but like the watcher
shows up
and it's kind of like yes right like the
world is basically ending this is what i
have been watching for the earth has
hours now at this point we actually get
an explanation on what's going on now to
give you guys an indication we're
literally getting an explanation about
the main bad guy in the first 12 pages
of this comic which should right off the
bat tell you that this being a six issue
limited series this plot goes way beyond
that and it does it gets really really
amazing so the whole thing as it's
explained to us is that we're told that
10 billion years ago a living machine
was created and that this living machine
existed to basically protect the
universe right to stop uh stop entropy
in the form of consuming black holes now
right off the bat that doesn't really
make any sense just because of the fact
that universes have black holes the
natural natural order of things that
when a star burns through basically
every elemental conversion it can it
eventually settles on what's in effect
ash and so basically the star just can't
maintain itself right it literally can't
keep itself going the gravitational pull
of the star outweighs the explosive
desire of the star to expand and so once
the star goes supernova that
gravitational pull just sucks everything
in and then boom you've got a
singularity a hole in space which
depending on what theory you follow with
may lead to another part of the universe
right like we don't understand anything
about black holes like i mean we can't
send probes in
nothing gets out of there so until we
achieve faster than light travel we'll
never be able to to go into a black hole
see what's there and escape all we know
is that you just basically get broken
down on the atomic level when you get
sucked in but the thing about this is
that the the purpose of this thing was
to basically consume black holes over
time ended up just becoming corrupted
now here's the funny thing about this
while this isn't necessarily the most
compelling story for this new cosmic
entity or a villain the reality is this
guy doesn't matter he's the least
important part of this story which is
another indication of how cool this
story is ultimately because of the fact
that it was so extreme it couldn't
physically be destroyed not by not even
by the living tribunal living tribunal
tried to destroy it but it couldn't be
destroyed by the living tribunal so the
only thing it did is it put it to sleep
and then stuck it in the core of a
planet which is basically turned out to
be earth and so it's just been there
ever since but by whatever manner and
whatever means the machine is waking up
and so as a result of that it's
literally trying to plow its way through
the world now this is when things get
nuts so this is one of the store because
you anybody who reads tom taylor you
guys know tom taylor's just like once
upon a time there was a a universe and
in this universe there was earth there
were superheroes and some bad things
were happening and so the superheroes
came together and then they all died and
then bad things happened and the world
exploded and this this that's how tom
taylor writes right that's how tom
taylor does things it's just it goes
from zero to 60 in the blink of an eye
and that's exactly what happens here so
what they end up doing is they basically
form what's basically a strike team
right now the vision is chosen a living
machine to fight a living machine the
scarlet witch is chosen because of her
ability to reshape reality and basically
fight against a being who could unmake
reality and then doctor strange was
chosen because apparently he's a
pinnacle of technology and then the
invisible woman to protect everybody
from the heat of the earth's core ben
grimm is chosen because if the thing
needs to be punched ben grimm is
probably the best person to do it which
i would argue would probably be the hulk
but following this they all basically
travel to the earth's core and they
encounter the unmaker right this machine
that's literally just trying to punch
its way out and so initially it totally
ignores them in the same way you would
expect it to right that like a cosmic
entity wouldn't really care about
regular beings here the other part of
this though is that we actually end up
switching over to wakanda now remember
wakanda is built on the great mound
right all that vibranium which basically
absorbs impact and so because of that
wakanda doesn't really feel the the
effects in the same way everybody else
does but they're still able to be
they're still able to feel it and they
know that something's going on there and
so in the end while all these other
places these other cities and these
other uh in these other countries are
just totally laid to waste by this
attack right even atlantis itself
completely and totally collapses the
superheroes all help where they can when
they can getting people out right trying
to rescue people from buildings all that
kind of stuff and what you end up having
here is of course ben grimm who
initially launches an attack against the
uh against the unmaker and is completely
obliterated right just absolutely
annihilated never stood a chance right
he's just completely and totally
destroyed at that point the scarlet
witch steps up and what's really cool
about this the way that peter explains
this it's nuts right the scarlet witch
attempted to reshape reality but despite
still waking to its full power the
unmaker simply unmade everything she
tried to do and then it unmade wanda
like literally she ceased to exist it
wiped her out of existence after that
vision goes and attacks it and then the
cool thing is that vision gives them
precious few seconds but there's not a
whole lot they can do that in essence
what it looks like is the unmaker had
basically absorbed the intelligence of
vision and that was basically the end of
him right there wasn't really anything
that could be done with with vision but
what doctor strange does in realizing
this thing is a living machine the
doctor strange basically like literally
scouts all these different alternate
realities that are out there all these
different dimensions that exist out
there and says okay there's got to be
one that's capable of bringing this guy
down now our initial thought here and
honestly this would have been a
phenomenal opportunity if this was like
like a 12 issue maxi series or if it was
like maybe kind of a i guess an expanded
maxi series that went on for 24 issues
or something like that or a multi-part
story is if he had just like summoned
out of desperation dormammu or somebody
like that right and just led to the ruin
of all or something along those lines
instead and it's not a terrible thing
here what he ends up doing is basically
opening a portal to a realm that
basically has an electromagnetic pulse
at the heart of it right it's just
constantly emanating an emp now what
this does while really it's only susan
storm and doctor strange who are left uh
what this does is it basically you know
it allows this emp to initiate the
problem is in the exact moment when the
portals open the unmaker realizes what
doctor strange is doing and then impales
him and then kills dr strange now of
course the the emp is enough to take
down the unmaker and doctor strange sims
susan storm away through a portal back
to uh back to the surface the problem is
that with doctor strange basically being
dead there's no way to close the portal
and so the basis behind the whole
concept of marvel dark ages is that with
this portal being stuck open and this
constant emp emanating from this
alternate reality and seemingly no one
having the ability to close the portal
it means there is a constant
electromagnetic pulse emanating
throughout the earth and it's it's nuts
because the way that peter parker
explains it he says but with strange
dead the portal stayed open he says the
constant emp wave grew and encompassed
the entire planet and beyond sending the
earth into darkness the sky literally
began to fall everything stopped from
powered suits to switches machines
sustaining life artificial life you know
even web shoes like the web shooters of
peter parker it all ended and so peter
parker is able to get right back to
where mary jane and and the kids are
supposed to be at least where his
daughter is supposed to be but when he
gets there the building is completely
and totally covered in rubble you do
have luke cage and you do have jessica
jones but what jessica jones says is
that like mary jane was in there trying
to get people out right she was trying
to help the last of the people evacuate
the building when the whole thing came
crumbling down and so in essence it
looks like peter parker's lost mary jane
watson but the crazy thing is he starts
digging through this rubble and when he
does what he finds is his daughter had
actually saved him which is adorable
it's god it's amazing
it's so cool his little girl's just
standing there she's like yeah
she's like holding up all this rubble
and everything which is really really
cool and of course you know that means
mary jane watson's life is effectively
safe but the cool thing about this and
this is this is what's this is what's
wild here right this is this is this is
what really got me into this because i
was like oh my god this is nuts so what
we're told is we jump forward seven
years and peter says seven years ago the
world we knew ended we built another
world a world to be proud of but years
after the lights went out after the end
came the apocalypse that like apocalypse
himself has basically marshaled his own
horsemen and in doing so is sending them
forward into the world presumably with
the intention of conquering it and
that's the thing these aren't just
regular four horsemen these are like
reed richards and like she-hulk and all
that stuff it's cool i would do this the
rest of this story is phenomenal it's
like one of the best stories some of the
best some of the best writing that
marvel's done in quite some time but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace
you